here we are on Mutual show on our set
but on Monday I was over at the Howard
Stern Show because Howard and Beth
wanted to do a little blind dating
situation and set me up with four
eligible bachelors that they were really
thoughtful about picking a lot of them
were personal friends six months ago
Howard and Beth were like why is she
still single let's do something about
this which is the nicest thing I think
anybody's ever done
but of course I am stubbornly myself and
so is Howard which I love um here's a
clip from the show all four of these
guys are quality guys I'm honored to
have them I believe that's why I I'm
like a part of me you must make the
decision or not no you've got to make
this I've never I never saw Chuck Barris
wrestle with the contestant I will go
against my own gut which was to say you
all know where to find me afterwards no
no no no no no Dan used to say men build
Bridges they want to get from one place
to the other and there's no way to get
there they build a bridge follow your
heart through women and men out there
it's true about the ghosts take it
personally
you're stonewalling I wanna hear one two
three or four and Howard I'm gonna make
a choice because you're not gonna let me
get away with it right I will pick
number two number two all right now Drew
and I came here
[Applause]
Bachelor number two Clark thorell
hi Clark hi Drew Clark how are you well
I love Howard and Beth I know you're
close to them to me I didn't go into
this
I I it brought up all of my like
relationship stuff I did a therapy
session before going on I start texting
Howard and Beth and I was like I'm still
processing like could I call Clark what
can I do and they're they were like not
only consenting they were encouraging
what were you going through yesterday
um I had people from all over my life
from 30 years ago all of a sudden
chiming in and saying did I just hear
you on the Howard Stern Show I didn't
tell anybody but you know like my two
best friends and my sister
um and uh so it was it was very surreal
I was getting all sorts of you know
people chiming in it was very surreal I
want to tell you a big part of why I
picked I picked you Clark I said you
know where are you at in your life right
now currently what are you looking for
and I felt in my gut that you were the
only person who gave an honest answer
which was I'm free I've showed up
open-minded open-hearted there's someone
else in the picture in the side
um enough to consider admitting and in
life I think we've got to reward people
for their honesty and moving forward
this is very important to me and it made
me trust you more that's really lovely
to hear thank you I appreciate it
um that said have you spoken to this
woman
um yeah we've been in touch with I mean
I gave her the point everything Clark
come on
she lives like 30 yards from where
you're shooting right now so um
she uh
honestly she's one of the best people
I've ever known and she said she just
sent you all sorts of love and blessings
and knows that we're exactly where we're
supposed to be did it bring up stuff
about your past and relationships and
what you're looking for did it did it
shift any Revelations like I'll give you
an example of a revelation I think I had
Clark which is that none of the
gentlemen including yourself have kids
and I have only dated in the last
few years men who don't have children I
want it clean I don't want to engage I
don't think anyone's meeting my kids I
don't know if this is going anywhere I
realized something yesterday Clark which
is I might live on planet parent and
when you don't live on planet parent
they're both of equal awesomeness
they're just a little bit different
planets and I I'm I'm intrigued because
I feel like I've never gone on a date
with someone who actually
understands the thing that's the most
all-consuming part of me what do you
think did you have any Revelations like
that or any shifts with regards to the
kids thing what you're mentioning I I
think I mentioned yesterday that
I feel like I am so familiar with that
kind of love
for whatever reason I feel it viscerally
I've always wanted kids I always thought
I was going to have kids but within the
last five years I'd say I've surrendered
that idea and it's it's really kind of
transmuted into an appreciation for
others in my life that are doing it and
also
um
my niece and nephews I mean they're
adults now but
um
I I I know that I'm going to have the
opportunity in this life to extend that
kind of love and and
um realize that capacity
for love and attention
huh
what'd I do
something very right
and on behalf of all single mothers the
fact that you and the other three
gentlemen would come on a show and be so
open armed to a single mom
on behalf of all of us thank you
[Music]